Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Imagina que estás viendo un tren
fuera de control por las vías
que va hacia cinco trabajadores
que no pueden escapar.
Te encuentras junto a un interruptor
que permite desviar el tren
a una segunda vía.
Este es el problema.
En esa vía también hay
un trabajador, pero solo uno.
¿Qué haces?
¿Sacrificas a una persona
para salvar a cinco?
Este es el problema del tren,
una versión de un dilema ético que
la filósofa Philippa Foot pensó en 1967.
Es popular porque nos obliga
a pensar cómo elegir
cuando no hay buenas opciones.
¿Elegimos la acción
que da el mejor resultado
o nos apegamos a un código moral que
prohíbe causar la muerte a alguien?
En un estudio un 90 % de los encuestados
dijo que está bien girar el interruptor,
dejar que muera un trabajador
para salvar a cinco.
Y otros estudios, que incluyen
una simulación del dilema,
han encontrado resultados similares.
Estos juicios son coherentes con el
principio filosófico del utilitarismo
que sostiene que la decisión
moralmente correcta
es el que maximiza el bienestar
para el mayor número de personas.
Cinco vidas superan a una,
incluso si el logro de ese resultado
requiere condenar a muerte a alguien.
Pero la gente no siempre
tiene la visión utilitarista,
algo que podemos ver cambiando
un poco el problema del tren.
Esta vez, estás parado
en un puente sobre la vía
conforme se acerca
el tren fuera de control.
Ahora no hay una segunda vía,
pero hay un hombre muy grande
en el puente a tu lado.
Si lo empujas, su cuerpo
detendrá el tren,
salvando a los cinco trabajadores,
pero morirá.
Para los utilitaristas, la decisión
es exactamente la misma,
perder una vida para salvar cinco.
Pero en este caso, solo
un 10 % de las personas
dice que está bien arrojar
al hombre a las vías.
El instinto nos dice que deliberadamente
causar la muerte de alguien
es diferente que dejar que muera
como un daño colateral.
Parece incorrecto por razones
difíciles de explicar.
Esta intersección entre
la ética y la psicología
es lo que hace tan interesante
el problema del tren.
El dilema en sus muchas variaciones revela
que lo que creemos correcto o incorrecto
depende de factores distintos
de un peso lógico de pros y contras.
Por ejemplo, es más probable que
los hombres digan que está bien
empujar al hombre al puente,
a que lo digan las mujeres.
Algunos ven un clip de comedia
antes de hacer el experimento mental.
Y en un estudio de realidad virtual,
esa gente estaba más dispuesta
a sacrificar a hombres que a mujeres.
Los investigadores han estudiado
la actividad cerebral
de la gente que piensa las versiones
clásica y la del puente.
Ambos escenarios activan áreas del cerebro
de toma de decisiones conscientes
y respuestas emocionales.
Pero en la versión del puente, la
respuesta emocional es mucho más fuerte.
Y también la actividad
en un área del cerebro
asociada al procesamiento
del conflicto interno.
¿Por qué la diferencia?
Una explicación es que empujar a alguien
a la muerte se vive como más personal,
y activa una aversión emocional
a matar a otra persona,
pero nos sentimos en conflicto porque
sabemos que es la decisión lógica.
La troleología ha sido criticada
por algunos filósofos y psicólogos.
Argumentan que no revela nada
pues su premisa es tan poco realista
que los participantes del estudio
no lo toman en serio.
Pero la nueva tecnología está haciendo
que este tipo de análisis ético
sea más importante que nunca.
Por ejemplo, los autos sin conductor
pueden tener que manejar opciones
como causar un pequeño accidente
para evitar uno mayor.
Mientras tanto, los gobiernos están
investigando drones militares autónomos
que podrían eliminar el tener que tomar
la decisión de arriesgar víctimas civiles
para atacar un objetivo de alto valor.
Si queremos que estas acciones
sean éticas,
tenemos que decidir de antemano
cómo valorar la vida humana
y juzgar el bien mayor.
Por eso los investigadores que
estudian los sistemas autónomos
están colaborando con los filósofos
para resolver el problema complejo
de programar la ética en las máquinas,
algo que muestra que incluso
los dilemas hipotéticos
pueden terminar colisionando
con el mundo real.